we are currently in a crisis of
leadership
so severe in the united states that
donald trump
spent his weekend retweeting videos of
himself
and threatening protesters with vicious
dogs
and violence from secret service agents
rather than leading uniting doing
something
productive because he doesn't know how
to do those things and according to one
white house report
the reason we've not heard from donald
trump something from the oval office a
message of unity
is that trump has nothing to say so
rather
he's staying quiet except not really
because he's tweeting uncontrollably
the u.s is devolving into chaos trump
spent the weekend retweeting videos of
himself
trying to take credit for the spacex
launch threatening protesters with
vicious dogs claiming he'll designate
antifa a terrorist organization he has
no idea what to do
it is a complete lack of leadership we
fortunately heard from former president
barack obama
with something that could be
approximating leadership
we're going to look at a couple of items
here starting with donald trump's
threats to unleash vicious dogs on
protesters he might as well have said
we're going to get the fire hoses out as
well there have been varying levels of
unrest around the country
stemming from the police killing of
george floyd this includes people near
the white house
trump tweeted on saturday about
protesters near the white house
check this out this incredibly ludicrous
rant trump saying quote
great job last night at the white house
by the u.s secret service they were not
only totally professional but
very cool i was inside watched every
move and
couldn't have felt more safe and they
let the protesters
scream and rant as much as they wanted
but whenever someone got too frisky or
out of line
they would quickly come down on them
hard didn't know what hit him
the front line was replaced with fresh
agents like magic
big crowd professionally organized but
nobody came close to breaching the fence
if they had they would have been greeted
with the most
vicious dogs and ominous weapons
i have ever seen that's when people
would have been really badly hurt
at least many secret service agents just
waiting for action we put the young ones
on the front
lines sir and they love it he might as
well be saying
secret service is thirsty for blood and
we're bringing out the fire hoses
release the hounds is what he is
essentially saying here
now this point about you know vicious
dogs and ominous weapons
that's bad enough the idea that young
secret service agents are just waiting
for action
that's trump admitting claiming i'm
guessing the secret service would would
not even agree with trump's
characterization this is trump claiming
that secret service is looking to beat
the crap out of people that's the
opposite of leadership
that's the opposite of bringing calm to
a nation
that is dealing with essentially the the
spanish flu
at the same time as some of the worst
uh civil uh unrest that we have seen
in addition to a complete lack of
federal leadership
all combined at the same time with a
recession
depression going on it's all happening
at once and trump is doing nothing
to actually bring people together a real
leader would ask for calm
a real leader would go to the oval
office and address the nation saying
we are a nation in struggle i hear you i
hear your concerns and your complaints
i'm committed to working together to
improve the country let's stop the
violence
let's stop the attack stop the violence
by police
let's realize that we are one nation
currently fighting a pandemic
and a recession depression no one
benefits from adding this chaos to the
pandemic i'm here with you on the
inequality in our justice system
i'm here with you on policing give me
the space and the calm
i need to work on this instead he
tweets threats about vicious dogs
retweets himself taking credit for the
rocket launch over the weekend that has
nothing to do with him
says hey antifa you're now a terrorist
organization which i will get to next
this is incompetence combined with
authoritarianism
from a wannabe dictator donald trump
don't for a second think that donald
trump by the way
is not deep down planning to use these
protests to further disrupt the 2020
election for his benefit unrest in major
cities
things are way too crazy for vote by
mail ballots will be
stolen or something we absolutely can't
do it
trump has the power of the bully pulpit
at any point he could say i'm going to
use that for good
he could do it now in so many ways the
country is plagued by challenges the
pandemic financial crisis
oppression discrimination coming to a
head and we have nothing from trump he
also tweeted
when the looting starts the shooting
starts that's a quote
from violent racist miami police chief
i forget his name years ago a tweet so
hideous
it was flagged by twitter as glorifying
violence
a real leader would dial down the anger
in the heat trump doesn't know how to do
that
so he's antagonizing protesters he's
riling up his own base he's firing up
the gun
people and he's not even pretending to
represent all americans here
trump opens his mouth and trash falls
out
that shouldn't surprise us anymore i
hope people are realizing the urgent
urgent nature of removing this president
and we've got to keep our eye on the
ball because the distractions keep
coming and that's what i want to talk
about next